vous êtes ici à malmaison dans la vue
de l'empereur là même où bonaparte puis
napoléon ont fait un certain nombre
d'évolutions pour la france de cette
époque
aujourd'hui on parle toujours de la
banque de france du code civil des
lycées d'un certain nombre de créations
comme les préfets et bien la majeure
partie de ces créations ont été soit
fondée ici soit ont germé dans l'esprit
de bonaparte et c'est ici à malmaison
que la plupart des grandes décisions ont
été prises alors l'histoire commence le
15 août 1769 ajaccio en corse
bonaparte n'est donc le 15 août 1769
dans une famille deuxième
deux des frères après après joseph un
certain nombre d'enfants vont ensuite
naître 13 au total et n'en demeurera
finalement de vivant q8 bonaparte va
perdre son père à l'âge de 16 ans et
charles bonaparte qui a créé et qui a
qu'à fonder une dynastie durable qui va
ensuite rayonner sur toute l'europe et
bien charles bonaparte va mourir en 1785
à montpellier alors sa famille surnomme
le jeu de paul est au repos l'yonne
c'est à dire celui qui se mêlent de tout
quel enfant était-il bonaparte et un
enfant turbulent un enfant car beaucoup
de caractère mais qui sait également
lorsqu'il est en grandes compagnies qui
s'est également dirigé qui s'est
également écouter ans le 15 mai 1779 il
entre avec de l'eau ligue 1 il est
disons c'est un arrachement pour bon à
part pour ce jeune napoléon bonaparte
c'est effectivement un arrachement c'est
un moment très douloureux puisqu'il faut
bien imaginer que passer d'ajaccio avec
sa douceur de vivre elle de vivre
ensuite à brienne dans la champagne qui
est assez une champagne crayeuse qui est
assez difficile
et puis avec une mentalité tout à fait
différente c'est très difficile pour ce
jeune garçon de 10 ans et son parcours
d'élèves va se faire de très bonnes
conditions dans de très bonnes
conditions mais également parce qu'il
montre un certain nombre de
caractéristiques de valeurs qui vont
tout de suite faire l'admiration de
certains de ses professeurs en
particulier en mathématiques ce qui va
d'ailleurs déterminé son rend ensuite à
l'école militaire de paris lorsqu'il
entre à partir de 1784 1785 et à ce
moment là on va diriger tout
naturellement vers larmes sa vente vers
la retirer alors il est sous le nom il a
16 ans quinze jours donné la précision
et un de ses professeurs écrit ce jeune
homme ira loin si les circonstances le
favorise la révolution à ce jeune
sous-lieutenant qui aurait pu terminer
comme finalement colonel du régiment et
qui aurait pu servir la royauté de
manière très traditionnelle bien les
événements vont se précipiter et de ce
bonaparte qui n'était finalement
destinés qu'à être un âne officiers
parmi tant d'autres eh bien les
conditions vont être réunies pour que le
destin de vienne extraordinaire le 30
juillet 1792 il est nommé capitaine
c'est louis saez qui s'ils sont brevets
et mécénat peu que l'on joue en réseau
voient effectivement il ne reste plus
que quelques jours à louis saez pour
régner sur la france et puis la prise
des tuileries en 1792 va marquer
durablement les esprits de bonaparte
evans marquer durablement sur l'ensemble
de sa carrière
il assiste avec avec son ami il son
condisciple bourienne dans l'appartement
du frère de bourienne aux pires horreurs
et de ses pires horreurs alors qu'il a
une idée un petit peu encore indécise
sur la suite des événements eh bien il
va se méfier ensuite de cette population
parisienne et il sera surtout se méfier
de ces mouvements de population qui
pourront aller à l'encontre de son
pouvoir central alors il est nommé et
cela finalement où tout va démarrer
comme andorre de l'artillerie à toulon
alors qu'est ce qui se passe à toulon la
ville est assiégée est bloqué par les
anglais bonaparte je voulais dit tout à
l'heure est un artilleur il est
finalement en avance sur son temps et va
provoquer à la fois les événements et il
reprend donc la ville de toulon assez
rapidement
en décembre 1793 alors à toulon le
capitaine camion c'est ainsi qu'on le
surnomme devient général de brigade
il n'a alors que 24 ans et il va devenir
général de brigade un grade qui est pas
tout à fait exceptionnelle pour le pour
son époque
mais surtout ce qui est assez
exceptionnel c'est qu'il le fait sur le
champ de bataille en à peine deux mois
ce qui hélas est exceptionnel puisque
normalement le grade de colonel les
grades successifs aurait dû l'amener le
conduire vers ce grade de général
seulement vers 30 35 ans et surtout des
événements s'accélèrent puisque à peine
quelques mois plus tard la france en
l'occurrence barras qui est devenu
directeur puisque je vous rappelle que
nous sommes à ce moment là autant du
directoire et bien barras a besoin de
lui pour mater une révolte qui tente de
réunir autour d'elle un certain nombre
de gens qui ne souhaitent souhaite pas
que là que la france accélère le
mouvement républicain il accepte de
mater cette révolte qui se trouve au
coeur de paris notamment devant l'église
saint roch le cac baisse de quel nom il
balaye les insurgés et le soleil
il sauve la république aidée notamment
par un certain nombre de lieutenant
fidèle en particulier de l'étonnant qui
vont devenir fidèles par la suite en
particulier un homme qu'on verra par la
suite à ses côtés à la fois dans son
cercle privé mais également auprès de
lui dans les champs de bataille c'est
notamment murat illégale et le site du
galon puisqu'il est nommé général de
division et commandeur en chef de
l'armée de l'intérieur et il rencontre
la compara le jeu le film au moment où
il devient général de division nous
sommes là donc en 1795 il gagne un
nouveau surnom le général vendémiaire et
il ne vient pour ainsi dire la véritable
coqueluche de paris ce personnage venu
de nulle part qui corse dont la
chevelure fait de lui un personnage un
petit peu avec 7,7 chevelure de chiens
abattus et bien le la gente féminine va
120 sont amusés dans un premier temps et
puis celle qui est auprès de barras
comme l'une des égéries du directoire de
la france de cette époque
joséphine marie-josèphe rose tâcher de
la pagerie qui était donc la veuve
beauharnais et bien s'amourache de ce
jeune bonaparte qu'il amuse beaucoup
et puis de cette rencontre est bien le
mariage va suivre assez rapidement et en
mars 1796 et bien bonaparte va épouser
celle qui va devenir à la fois sa
protectrice son initiatrice et puis
surtout sa bonne étoile et barras a mis
dans la corbeille de mariée il va donner
à bonaparte
un cadeau qui est un petit peu
empoisonné qui est celle de général de
l'armée d'italie ou un appart de cette
armée de gueux ni qui n'a pas
véritablement d'intérêt pour le pouvoir
parisien de cette armée en guenilles il
va faire une arme et conquérante et de
cette arme et conquérante
il va faire finalement l'admiration de
l'europe alors le 27 mars 1796 il arrive
à nice et les généraux blanchi sous le
harnais regarde un peu de haut ce jeu de
blanc bec mais il va le calmer tout de
suite faut bien imaginer que cette
arrivée de bonaparte à l'armée d'italie
choc surprend et puis surtout on se dit
mais c'est finalement ce personnage
c'est finalement la créature de bach à
ce qu'on nous met dans nos dans nos
pattes
c'est un personnage davantage politique
que finalement un militaire qu'on nous
met là donc on va pas suivre ses
instructions
il a fait peut-être quelques mouvements
intéressants à toulon et à sa route mais
ça s'arrête là
que va-t-il faire avec une véritable
armée
et que va-t-il nous donner comme
instruction alors qu'il n'a jamais
réellement diriger une armée est bien de
cette armée qui est parti de nulle part
où les vieilles barbes les les cheveux
grisonnants que son nez augereau par
exemple les délais masséna et bien ils
vont suivre ses instructions parce que
il est persuadé qu'avec de la vitesse et
de l'enthousiasmé on peut parvenir à
toutes les solutions et c'est ce qui va
faire avec un certain nombre de
batailles qui vont suivre alors des
victoires de légende monde le dit cathy
bio d'arcole et puis le 14 janvier 1797
rivoli les portes de vienne sont
ouvertes et l'europe stupéfaite
ce qui change c'est surtout que
bonaparte conduit ses troupes lui même
c'est ce qui change énormément
il ne craint pas le feu il prend la
direction des événements même si
forcément la légende s'en est emparé
avec beaucoup d'exagération par la suite
mais du moins il montre l'exemple
il prend la conduite des opérations il
innove il devient moderne parce que il
conduit ses troupes de manière autonome
et il leur indique finalement à chacune
ce qu'il faut faire et ensuite laisse
travailler
alors qu'auparavant les généraux sur le
champ de bataille dirigé avec le bâton à
manière un peu en plus mais il faut bien
l'avouer bien l'avouer est bien
bonaparte le fait avec beaucoup
d'instruction et surtout de persuasion
et c'est ça qui va surtout faire son
génie de cette époque alors les
bonaparte avait chassé les autrichiens
du tabbee évolutions géopolitiques
avec ce traité conforme you ce qui est
intéressant dans ce cas précis c'est que
bonaparte qui n'est finalement qu'un
général parmi d'autres de la république
traite comme un chef d'état
il devient finalement le prochain
prochain homme politique qui va compter
en france ils traitent directement avec
les stars 2 tout d'abord dans le premier
traité qui est fait en 1796 et ensuite à
campo fort mieux avec les autrichiens il
dit à la fois un traité de paix directif
mais également qui permet au nord de
l'italie
quasiment dans sa globalité de devenir
indépendante bonaparte dans cette dans
le nord de l'italie
vient finalement le personnage capital
avec lequel il va falloir compter la
peau barras il était important
d'éloigner ce jeune général ce sera des
chips on le nomme commandant en chef de
l'armée d'orient en 1798 et là la grande
aventure commence
il faut gagner d'autres lauriers et
c'est ce que va donner notamment cette
campagne d'égypte et de syrie qui va
suivre
il rêve d'orient parce que comme
alexandre comme césar également mais
surtout comme alexandre et bien rien de
grand ne s'est fait dans le monde qu'en
orient alors le 1er juillet 1798 la
remise au client débarque avec son
brillant d'égypte et outre les soldats
il ya des savons ça c'est une idée
géniale
bon à part depuis quelques mois à peine
est devenu membre de l'institut de
france cet institut de france réuni un
certain nombre de savants de
personnalités de personnes qui cherchent
par tous les moyens à accélérer les
connaissances que l'on peut avoir de ce
qu avait notamment inscrit dans la
continuité l'encyclopédie de diderot et
d'alembert et bien il devient l'homme
qu'il faut suivre
et cette flamme que l'on va suivre cette
lumière nouvelle qui va débarquer en
egypte elle va être entouré de 167
savant qui vont de manière assez
efficace découvrir à la fois toutes les
richesses de la faune de la flore de
l'architecturé de l'archéologie d'égypte
mais également découvrir la population
égyptienne qui vit actuellement est un
institut d'égypte va créer à ce moment
là alors le 20 juillet 798 c'est la
victoire des pyramides soldats du haut
de ces pyramides quarante chevaux
comtois bonaparte a le sens des formules
il sait trouver les mots qui frappent
soldats du haut de ces pyramides
quarante siècles vous contemplent est
effectivement pour ses soldats ils
s'imaginent reprendre les pas de ces
armes est à la fois de césar à la fois
d'octave à la fois d'augusta la fois
d'alexandre et en ce mois de juillet
1790 vite bonaparte prend le dessus sur
les armes et mamelouks
des pyramides c'est une victoire
française éclatante on a très peu de
morts et de blessés au vu des milliers
de blogs
alors bonaparte va prendre la stratégie
de la tortue qui avait utilisé notamment
les troupes impériales romaine autrefois
c'est à dire qu'on se concentre et on
attend que les troupes adverses qui
viennent avec des cavaliers se brise
comme comme du verre sur ces carrés et
que l'on repousse ensuite avec avec
force force artillerie et bien cette
stratégie et va être payante notamment
ici donc au moment de la bataille des
pyramides mais elle va l'être également
sur la suite des événements jusqu'au
moment des campagnes en syrie les
pyramides une grande victoire aboukir
défaite
nelson arrive à coincer le club
française et à la détruire
donc on peut dire que lola pas
prisonnier de sa conquête bonaparte va
devenir prisonnier de sa conquête parce
que les événements vont se liguer contre
lui tout d'abord parce que nelson
parvient enfin à mettre la main sur la
flotte française
et puis surtout les ordres que bonaparte
avait donné à l'amiral bruay qui
dirigeait cette flotte française ne
parviennent pas attendre et napoléon
bonaparte avec l'ensemble de ses troupes
de vienne finalement prisonniers de leur
conquête
dans un second temps lorsque la campagne
d'egypte et de syrie s'achèvera c'est la
même à aboukir pour toujours marqué les
esprits que bonaparte va tenter une
bataille décisive contre troupe
mamelouks qui va y parvenir mais cette
fois-ci non pas sur les mer mais à terre
avec en particulier une charge
dantesques et qui va rester dans
dans le mythe de la cavalerie française
une charge qui est conduite en
particulier par lan mais également par
le futur général de murat alors il va
confier en fait l'armée française au
général kléber et il décide de rentrer
en france pourquoi il lui faut surtout
reprendre le contrôle des événements
parce que le directoire des associations
très difficile les troupes à la fois en
italie mais également sur le nord de
l'europe ont été repoussés donc il lui
faut reprendre la main à la fois
militairement mais également
politiquement ou dans la france se
donner de la partie et ce jour d'état du
18 brumaire le personnage central de
coup d'état du 18 brumaire des 18 et 19
brumaire nous sommes alors en novembre
1799 le personnage central ça n'est pas
bonaparte le personnage central c'est
l'abbé sieyès vous avez l'abbé sieyès
qui avait dit qu'est ce que le kers état
il n'est rien en 1789 dans l'esprit de
seyes bonaparte n'est finalement qu'un
élément on peut pas dire un pion mais un
élément l'élément militaire on va dire
mais comme lui dira d'ailleurs bonaparte
après la après ce coup d'état de
brumaire qui s'achève vous le savez à
saint cloud en novembre 2 799 un saut ce
10 novembre 1799 et bien bonaparte ne
veut pas être entre guillemets c'est à
ces mots le cochon à l'engrais qu on le
destine on le destine à être devenir un
consul parmi tant d'autres pour lui une
seule solution c'est de venir le premier
consul
les deux autres n'étant que des
comparses que l'on mènera comme on le
souhaite la france est dans un état très
difficile de france pratiquement dévasté
économiquement il retrousse ses manches
et à l'oral la période du consulat ce
sont les grandes réformes lesquelles bon
à part te faire un certain nombre de
mesures à prendre un certain nombre de
mesures à la fois économique où les
caisses de l'état se remplissent de
nouveau
la deuxième chose elle est d'ordre
uniquement institutionnels et bonaparte
va instaurer ces éléments importants
pour redonner à la fois confiance mais
donner un certain nombre de directives
dans un certain nombre de domaines
et puis surtout et puis surtout le grand
code qu'attendait la france depuis
quasiment une cinquantaine d'années un
certain nombre de lois qui étaient les
mêmes pour l'ensemble du pays et cet
ensemble de codes ce sera bien entendu
ce code civil qui va être instaurée à la
fin du consulat en 1804 le consulat
c'est une période florissante un travail
énorme et a battu la france est
totalement réorganisé la paix avec
extérieur l'appellent les anglais et
aussi la paix à l'intérieur où les
royalistes sont calmés par l'ona à la
fois à l'intérieur avec les émigrés ces
émigrés qui était parti de france et qui
vont enfin rentrer puisque les décisions
sont prises pour que le retour des
émigrés sont possibles et puis surtout
parce que la paix religieuse est fait il
faut bien se rappeler que le pape pie
vii qui doit sont en partie son
accession au trône de saint pierre est
bien le dois aux français et en
particulier à bonaparte et bien le pape
pie vii à traiter avec bonaparte pour
signer ce concordat en 1801 et à partir
de là du mois donc d'avril et de mai
1802 les premières messes vont se
dérouler en france et les catholiques
qui était autrefois banny puisqu'on se
souvient qu'avec la révolution la
religion était interdite et bien enfin
la paix est faite à la fois religieuse
mans on l'a dit politiquement mais
également pour les économiquement et il
en impose et à l'europe avec la deuxième
compagnie d'italie et la victoire de
marengo si bien que on lui propose de
venir conçu la vie et puis après
empereur il est sacré le 2 décembre 1804
à notre dame
un certain nombre d'événements vont
provoquer cette marche au consulat à
vicky donc devient un pouvoir également
héréditaire également vers l' empire
tout d'abord bonaparte est victime d'un
attentat manqué sur la rue saint-nicaise
on a tenté avec une machine infernale de
faire mourir
happart donc son pouvoir qu'il croyait
indestructible ne tient qu'à un fil
finalement et puis surtout il ya un
autre événement qui va se dérouler c'est
que bonaparte fait arrêter le duc
d'enghien qui tentaient de faire revenir
au pouvoir le roi en l'occurrence le 18
sans doute les circonstances se
sont-elles accéléré bonaparte n'a pas
regardé d'un assez bon oeil cet
événement et le duc d'enghien ce fait
jugé trop rapidement et se fait ensuite
exécuté dans les fossés de vincennes et
cette marche
cette marche imparable vers l'empiré se
fait en particulier avec cette mort du
duc d'enghien donc mon appart n'a plus
qu'une seule possibilité pour traiter
d'égal à égal avec les autres rois qui
l'entourent ça n'est pas de bien sûr
établir une royauté puisque depuis des
792 et surtout de la mort de louis seize
ans 93 en janvier 93 il n'est plus
possible d'avoir un roi
alors on tente de rétablir ce qui avait
été le cas notamment sous l'antiquité et
sous charlemagne de rétablir un empire
français dont la france et d'autres pays
voisins sauf que l'angleterre va
prévenir le traité et donc incapable
décide d'en finir avec les anglais et
d'envahir l'angleterre alors bonaparte
dans un premier temps prépare près par
cette nouvelle campagne qui s'annonce
contre les anglais sa première idée on
s'en doute ces deux d'aller chercher les
anglais là où se trouve tout simplement
sur les îles et donc d'aller à londres
et de rétablir ce traité damien qui
vient d'être d'être rompu en particulier
pour une raison importante
on sait bien que les anglais ne voulait
pas d'un pouvoir héritiers de la
révolution en france
il tentait par tous les moyens de
rétablir le trône de louis xviii
mais bonaparte va plus loin il prépare
ses troupes ce qu'on a dit le camp de
boulogne ce n'est pas uniquement qu'à
boulogne-sur-mer s'est également tout au
long de cette côte
cette côte de la manche ses côtes de la
manche qui vont aller jusqu'à la
belgique actuelle et il prépare ses
troupes et les aguerris dans un certain
but un but bien sûr d'invasion de
l'angleterre
mais si bien que lorsque les événements
vont se traduire autrement et que les
autrichiens quasiment un an jour pour
jour après son sacre à notre-dame et
bien commence à envahir l'alliée de la
france qui est la bavière donc bonaparte
au mois d'août et au mois de septembre
1805 et bien renvoie ses troupes qui se
préparait pour l'invasion d'angleterre
il les renvoie vers le centre de
l'europe et va les diriger vers les
autrichiens qui va battre successivement
jusqu'à la bataille décisive
d'austerlitz un an jour pour jour après
le sacre de notre dame nous sommes alors
le 2 décembre 1805
la ville doit plus parfaite de la
tendance la victoire d'austerlitz que la
france n'a pas commémoré avec le
bicentenaire en 2005 cette dite en
service elle reste elle demeure l'une
des plus fameuses l'une des plus grandes
victoires à la fois tactique parce que
bonaparte parvient à écraser les deux
empereurs qui lui font face à la fois
l'empereur d'autriche et l'empereur de
russie avec des troupes considérable
face à lui dans un petit périmètre
mais surtout ce qui est considérable
c'est que ces armées qui restent les
armées de la république nous sommes
alors encore en 1805 et l'impôt l'on est
encore je le répète empereur de la
république française eh bien ces armées
de la république
elles vont faire de ce champ de bataille
d'austerlitz aujourd'hui savent qu offre
qui se trouvent en république tchèque
il va battre successivement ses troupes
donc austro russe la plus grande
victoire française alors les angles
perdu déjà une première manche cette
campagne a été fait avec leur anglais là
il se retourne de la caution qui vont
inciter les postières ont déclaré la
guerre à la france on est en 1806 que se
passe-t-il
quelques mois avant cette campagne
militaire victorieuse d'ulm et ensuite
d'austerlitz 2805 les lisent les
prussiens s'était gardé de s'engager
trop en avant en se demandant s'il
fallait suivre ce mot n'a pas redevenu
napoléon ou s'il fallait devenir un des
alliés des troupes austro russe il
s'engage dans une dans une campagne en
se disant qu'ils sont les descendants de
ceux frédéric 2,6 conquérant et si
victorieux et que ce napoléon ne va être
finalement qu'un qu'un éléments
disparates et qu'on va pouvoir repousser
à paris sans fin sans difficulté ce
qu'ils oublient c'est que napoléon va
battre successivement ses troupes
toujours avec des moments importants ce
sera tout d'abord iéna à hochstatt
double victoire du 14 octobre 1806 où
les troupes conduites par napoléon mais
également à hochstatt parce que napoléon
conduit ses troupes victorieusement à
iéna avec notamment n'est qu'ils
chargent victorieusement les troupes
prussiennes mais surtout dans un autre
champ de bataille non loin de là à
hochstatt et bien le général devenu
maréchal davout va repousser les troupes
prussiennes et va conduire les troupes
françaises et bien en direction de
berlin qui sera prise en octobre
prochain
l'euro quatre mois d'appeler ou
la pousse à genoux et le 26 novembre
1806 il prend un décret très important
le décret instituant le blocus
continental pour lutter contre les
angles la guerre de l'économie
la guerre qui était un an dans un
premier temps une guerre stratégique une
guerre tout simplement militaire comme
on s'y attendait mais également
politique parce que c'est toujours dans
l'esprit de napoléon et de son entourage
c'est toujours les idées qui doivent
aussi être promue dans cette dans cet
esprit de napoléon il faut conduire les
populations européennes a accepté le
code civil tout simplement à accepter
l'idée de la révolution qui se propage
en europe
eh bien on va tout simplement cherché à
mettre un terme à la puissance dominante
de l'angleterre par là où elle pêche et
bien tout simplement par son pouvoir
économique
là où apple parce que l'économie
anglaise n'est plus aussi florissantes
qu'elle l'était quelques années
auparavant
tout simplement parce que les
territoires pris successivement par les
troupes françaises ont affaibli
l'économie anglaise qui ne trouvent plus
de débouchés les russes décident de
venir à l'aide des poussières naples et
aux marcheurs l'est c'est la terrible
bataille d'eylau en 1807 et tout ça se
termine le capteur jour par la victoire
française de free et de l'ordre
qu'est-ce que ça va changer
napoléon n'a pas pu faire la paix avec
les autrichiens durablement mais du
moins avec le traité de presse book en
les choses sont arrêtées avec les russes
qui ont été battus à austerlitz
les russes n'ont pas tenté cette cette
paix durable et lorsque les prussiens en
1806 l'année suivante ont dû mettre bas
les armes et bien les russes ont repris
le flambeau et ont tenté par tous les
moyens de repousser ce napoléon qui
commence à prendre pas sur leur
territoire traditionnel
ce sera surtout le cas avec la bataille
de free landes du 14 juin 1800 7 le 14
juin
d'ailleurs comme marengo c'est une date
glorieuse pour napoléon
c'est là qu'il va battre les russes sur
leur territoire sur le champ de bataille
qu'ils avaient choisis et napoléon
parvis
enfin à instaurer une paix durable avec
les russes
cette rencontre marquante est symbolique
entre les deux empereurs et se fera donc
à t-il site aujourd'hui dans ce
territoire russe qui se trouve non loin
de kaliningrad un konigsberg à l'époque
c'est là que l'empereur de russie le
tsar va rencontrer l'empereur des
français et qu'ils vont décider à n'ont
pas pas tout à fait une sorte de yalta
bhl de cette époque mais un petit peu de
se répartir les tâches de se répartir un
petit peu les territoires européens
du moins de se faire une paix qui sera
une paie de compromis et cette ati site
sur le radeau donc c'est très symbolique
au bord du nil mène ce lieu même où la
rencontre entre l'occident et l'orient
se fait que les deux empereurs ont
décidé d'une paix alors une paie de
dupes pour napoléon parce qu'il
considère l'empereur de russie comme son
égal mais le tsar est tout à fait
francophobe donc cette paix n est fait
pour les russes que pour gagner du temps
alors justement les anglais reprennent
du terrain en espagne via le portugal
qu'ils investissent et d'appeler on
pense avoir les mains libres pour
traiter à sa première les affaires
ibérique napoléon l'année suivante de ce
traité de tilsit qui a enfin fait la
paix c'est du moins ce qu'ils imaginent
pour l'europe est obligé de reprendre
les choses en main en espagne en espagne
il a dans un premier temps attiré dans
un guet-apens il faut bien dire
à bayonne le roi d'espagne charles iv et
son fils le futur ferdinand 7 pour leur
demander d' abdiquer en sa faveur en sa
faveur dans un premier temps pour
redonner ensuite c'est un petit peu ce
que chateaubriand racontera ou lorsque
le murat et joseph vont se répartir les
trônes un petit peu il dit d'être cerné
un petit peu comme des sous préfets et
bien non napoléon dans un premier temps
souhaite que cette espagne soit
florissante et il va instaurer un
pouvoir central dirigée par son propre
frère joseph qu'il va devenir joseph
promis et d'espagne mais pour accélérer
mouvement et bien il va prendre les
choses en main napoléon entre à madrid
en décembre 1808 et instaure du moins
c'est dans son esprit un store
durablement son frère sur le trône
d'espagne
or les élites espagnols sont très pro
française le verger est farouchement
anti français pour le clergé espagnols
n'avaient l'once est l'antéchrist dans
l'esprit de napoléon en arrivant avec
les idées de la révolution
les choses vont se dérouler tels qu'ils
imaginent tels que ça s'est passé
notamment en italie ou en autriche ou
même même à berlin
il va apporter la paix et va apporter la
liberté l'égalité la fraternité
c'était bien sûr les mots qui est encore
qui sont encore au fronton des des
bâtiments publics et ils les apporte là
en espagne alors dix ans mais fait comme
bon vous semble
nous aurons une administration qui sera
dirigé peut-être par des français mais
progressivement vous allez prendre en
main votre destin
il n'a pas pris en compte un élément
très important c'est la puissance de
l'église en espagne la puissance de
l'église qui ne souhaite pas qu'on lui
impose les articles organique c'est à
dire la liberté de culte la tolérance
religieuse et surtout qui ne souhaite
pas qu'on prenne sa puissance financière
qui est considérable en espagne et sa
puissance tout simplement d'options et
d'opinion sur la population
donc la religion et surtout un certain
nombre de de clergé va se soulever
contre napoléon et va instaurer un
certain nombre de mouvements
contestataires et de rébellion avec ses
fameux troupe de résistance qui vont
continuellement tenté par tous les
moyens de mettre un terme à la puissance
française en espagne une guérilla très
dur l'armée française va s'embourber où
l'espace est le mot juste
ça donne des idées aux autrichiens qui
en 1809 se réveille et déclare une
nouvelle fois la guerre à la france
avant même que le bon bien espagnol une
phase en sorte que la france soit
obligée de se retirer et que joseph
rentrant en france progressivement
jusqu'en 1814 et chose donc pas se
dérouler rapidement et bien les
autrichiens profitent de cet éloignement
intempestives de
de napoléon en 1808 pour tenter de
reprendre les choses notamment sur leur
territoire mais également sur la bavière
sur lequel il lorgne depuis un certain
temps et napoléon redirige ses troupes
et un certain nombre de ses soldats vers
l'autriche
bien entendu la tactique et la stratégie
continuent de porter leurs fruits et
napoléon à la fois en bavière dans un
premier temps mais également en autriche
va parvenir à ses fins seulement à
partir du mois de juillet 1809
il est prisonnier du danube et de cette
bataille décisive qui l'attend elle va
arriver seulement les 5 et 6 juillet
1809 avec la bataille de wagram
il va pas revenir enfin mettre un genou
à terre à cette autriche qui continue de
narguer et dans 2
la corbeille et bien de cette paix et
bien il y aura une mariée une belle
mariée qui sera l'archiduchesse marie
louise et divorce de joséphine qu'il
adore parce que le peuvent à lui donner
d'héritier
ce sera donc une archiduchesse comment
ça se fait traiter cette affaire
napoléon va donc que divorcé d'avec
joséphine en décembre 1809 à son corps
défendant mais également parce qu'il a
une idée en tête il n'est plus le
général bonaparte qui avait sept
cette fameuse étoile qui est à ses côtés
et qui était d'ailleurs une étoile
victorieuse avec joséphine
ils s'imaginent être l'égal des autres
rois et reines d'europe mais également
des empereurs autrichien et russe et
pour ce faire pour durablement instauré
son pouvoir en france
ils s'imaginent et bien tout simplement
entrer dans cette famille des rois et
des empereurs et bien il se cherche une
nouvelle impératrice et cette jeune
fille c'est marie louise qui alors à
peine 16 ans le 20 mars 1811 le roi de
rome
mais ce n'est pas le premier film qui
s'est déroulée dans l'esprit de napoléon
c'est que d'un divorce d'avec joséphine
il fallait surtout un héritier de ce
divorce
il a été également accéléré parce que
napoléon appris qu'il a été père naturel
de deux autres enfants dans un premier
temps du comte léon de cet enfant qu'il
a eu avec elle au nord de noël de la
plaine qui était une lectrice de la
reine hortense la fille joséphine sa
belle-fille et puis également parce
qu'il est devenu père du jeune enfant
qu'il a eu avec ses amours avec une
polonaise marc ivanov ce cas du jeune
alexandre qui valut à lui de confirmer
qu'il peut devenir père alors qu'il se
croyait stérile on sait que joséphine
avait eu deux autres enfants avant son
mariage avec napoléon eugène et hortense
et que tout le monde pensait que jeune
apollon ne pourrait pas être père avec
ces deux confirmations et bien il eut
pour cet héritier et cet héritier
naturel bien marie louise va lui offrir
le 20 mars 1811 laissant un coup de
canon vont être tirés des tuileries
enfin la paix et durable sur toute
l'europe enfin l'empiré fait désormais
le pouvoir de napoléon et illimité ans
18 sur 12 ont gelé sur le bord 1e elle
et il va rentrer en russie
pourquoi cette guerre napoléon s'était
mis la puce à l'oreille avec un
événement qui s'était déroulé quelques
temps auparavant lorsqu'il avait tenté
par tous les moyens dans un premier
temps d'avoir une épouse d'origine russe
mais si le tsar lui a refusé sa soeur
pour devenir impératrice des français
c'est que déjà germé dans son esprit une
guerre possible ou du moins une rupture
de l'appétit site qui on l'a dit tout à
l'heure et est un jeu de dupes entre les
hommes alors napoléon prend les devants
et conduit ses troupes au bord du yémen
et comme autrefois césar avec le rubicon
et bien franchi le yémen pour se diriger
vers moscou moscou parce que c'est là
qu'ils imaginent être le pouvoir ce
n'est pas la capitale mais c'est le
pouvoir central et surtout économique du
pays c'est à moscou qu'il faut être
parce qu'il faut marquer les esprits et
mettre un terme dans les esprits russe à
cette lutte continuelle qu'ils ont
contre les français c'est une immense
hervé europe et des centaines de
milliers d'hommes qui franchit les mails
les troupes que réunit et napoléon en
1812 sont considérables c'est la plus
grande armée peut-être jamais réunie par
un chef d'état moderne par un chef de
guerre surtout on compte entre 500 et
600 mille hommes qui sont réunis pour
s'engager dans cette nouvelle campagne
qu'on appelle d'ailleurs à l'époque
seulement seconde campagne de pologne et
qui va devenir une campagne de russie
parce que les troupes s'avance si loin
qu'elles vont aller jusqu'à moscou
a moscou les choses ne se passent pas
comme c'était prévu dans un premier
temps on ne va pas s'installer à moscou
et se ravitailler parce que les on le
sait les russes vont brûler leur ville
sous les ordres de rostopchine vont
brûler leur ville et vont mettre un
terme à ce ravitaillement que les
français espérait nous sommes alors
pendant les trente cinq jours
d'occupation de moscou nous sommes alors
à la fin de
de cet automne qui s'achève dans des
conditions plutôt agréable à ce moment
là mais naples on sait bien qu'il lui
faut revenir pour avoir un
ravitaillement qui se fasse dans de
bonnes conditions et le jeu ni allah ni
versé de la partie et ce général hiver
qui connaissent bien les russes cet
hiver terrible où le thermomètre ne va
cesser de baisser et de cette arme est
parti avec 500 à 600 mille hommes
la retraite de russie qui va tout de
même s'achever par une victoire qui
essaient de la bérézina on parle
toujours de la bérézina comme un terme
où on aurait perdu ses troupes
en réalité c'est surtout après la
bérézina quitte une bataille gagnée par
les français c'est surtout après que
cette retraite de russie va être
terrible et napoléon laisse ses troupes
le 5 décembre 1812 has more money et
repart vers l'écurie parce que à ce
moment là en france on a profité
l'absence de napoléon pour reprendre le
pouvoir avec une tentative de coup
d'état
celle du général malaise ce qui prouve
bien que le pouvoir de napoléon ne tient
finalement qu'à un fil et que il est
trés est très difficile pour lui d'
instaurer un pouvoir héréditaire
continue alors la retraite de russie et
la perte de la grande armée de les
appétits et européens on est en 1813
ça va être une nouvelle campagne
d'allemagne alors tandis que les troupes
sont mises à mal et que naples on est en
train de reconstituer ses effectifs
il n'a plus de cavalerie puisque la
plupart sont morts à la fois les chevaux
mais également les hommes qui les
conduisait sont morts dans les plaines
dans les plaines de russie et donc il va
faire appel un certain nombre de troupes
de conscrits qui vont être appelés en
urgence mêmes qui vont devancer l'appel
pour reconstituer des troupes donc ils
sont peu aguerris mais très enthousiaste
et très jeune et il va les utiliser pour
cette campagne qui s'annonce cette
campagne du 113 puisque à la fois les
russes les autrichiens mais également
les prussiens toujours avec leur anglais
ses torts anglais qui ne cesse d
alimenter alors en mai du 113
napoléon gagne zen à bilzen addressed de
26 et 27 août
mais il perd à la logique en octobre ce
sont les autrichiens aidés par les
russes et par les prussiens qui vont
reprendre les événements et qui vont
diriger napoléon vers le point
névralgique ce point névralgique sera
épique la défaite de la musique débouche
sur la campagne de france et pour la
première fois la france est envoyé à la
map les wafers napoléon redevient en
janvier 1814 alors qu'elle confie le
pouvoir à l'impératrice marie-louise
également à son frère joseph qui
rentrait d'espagne et qui devient
lieutenant général de l' empire
eh bien il redevient le bonaparte qu'on
a connu 1796 97 de celui de la première
campagne italie ce n'est plus des
guerres de conquête mais c'est d'une
protection du territoire protection du
territoire également des idées c'est
toujours la république qui se bat contre
les troupes coalisées monarchique est
entre guillemets féodal c'est le terme
qu'il utilise lui même encore à l'époque
donc on se bat pour des idées pour
défendre le territoire et on va le faire
avec des troupes qui sont assez jeunes
puisque les troupes qui ont été réunis
là pour une large part ce sont des
jeunes gars ce sont des soldats qui ont
été des conscrits assez récents qui ont
dit entre 18 et 25 ans et qui n'ont pas
forcément l'expérience même s'ils sont
entourés par un certain nombre de
soldats des big moustache et la grande
la vieille garde et puis l'autre
d'autres soldats qui ont fait d'autres
campagnes mais la plupart sont très peu
aguerris et donc ne connaissent pas
forcément ni la tactique napoléon et
avec l' enthousiasme avec sa présente
même notamment lorsque la montre au par
exemple il reprend le canon lui-même il
donne la directive donne l'exemple à
suivre
et c'est seule sa seule présence fait en
sorte que bien des prouesses sont
exercés mais forcément face à des
troupes qui sont beaucoup plus
nombreuses face à des troupes également
qui même si elles sont divisées
parviennent tout de même à repousser
l'échéance
et bien cette séance à les repousser
surtout jusqu'en mars et en avril 1814
et bien napoléon est obligé d'abdiquer
il avait tenté une dernière
une dernière possibilité sur paris ou
peut-être même vers le sud
mais ses maréchaux cette fois ci est
bien lui laisse sur le bureau de manière
symbolique sans leur bâton de maréchal
et décide cette fois-ci d'arrêter les
frais le 20 avril les adieux de
fontainebleau et napoléon pas pour lui
d'elle dont il est le souverain
confettis dans la littérature avec un
certain nombre de derniers fidèles comme
cambronne comme drouot
eh bien il va se diriger vers son
premier exil cet exil qu'on lui dessine
il n'est pas tout à fait un exilé
prisonniers puisqu'ils comptent ils
continuent d'être empereur mais cette
fois ci avec un royaume seulement
serions c'est le la petite île de l'île
d'elbe qui n'est pas très loin de cette
course qu'il aime tant et dans ces
royaumes de l'île d'elle où il parvient
donc mois de mai 1814 qui était
française déjà depuis un certain temps
depuis 1802 et bien de cette île d'elbe
il va faire un champ d'expérimentation
et va faire une île tout à fait
florissante dont les anglais les
autrichiens les prussiens et les russes
ont tombé dans leurs bagages
le 18 qui est venu à paris le 18 soit
rentré à paris un peu forcé par les
événements et puis la population qui est
là c'est évidemment on s'en doute des
guerres continuelle depuis 1792 accueil
à bien avec un insoumis enthousiaste il
faut bien le dire
ce roi peau d'agr assez gros et qui qui
ne ressemble pas du tout aux jeunes
apollons qu'on avait connue en 1804 et
bien ce roi va s'installer à aux
tuileries avec un certain nombre de
mesures qui ne vont pas être populaire
dans un premier temps surtout les
conditions économiques sont très
favorables à un retour du roi il faut
bien imaginer que des guerres
successives ont affaibli la puissance
française et puis surtout il faut payer
un certain tribu aussi aux troupes de
d'invasion qui sont installés notamment
sur les champs elysées on a tous en tête
ces images de ces de ses ruses qui vont
d'ailleurs laissé certain nombre de
dans la langue française comme ce bistro
parce qu'ils voulaient vivre et voir
vite au café et donc bistrot bistrot ça
veut dire donc rapidement donc ses
troupes d'occupation et vont laisser un
mauvaise image à la population française
et puis politiquement le 18 rétabli
quasiment trait pour trait ce qui
s'était déroulé avant lui même s'ils
gardent quelques images précédent
quelques symboles précédent comme la
légion d'honneur
les troupes n'ont plus aucun exercice à
faire la plupart sont laissés en demi
soldes puisque les officiers qu'ils ne
sont plus en exercice on leur donne la
demi solde donc le demi traitement
et puis eh bien ça manque de chaleur ça
manque d' enthousiasme ça manque de rêve
dans tout ça et ce rêve est bien
napoléon fall va lui donner avec la
tentative ses tentatives terrible est
formidable des 100 jours de 1115 le 1er
mars
il débarque à golfe-juan on est en 1815
le 20 mars il avoue qu il rit c'est une
remontée de la france absolument il
avait dit effectivement à ses
lieutenants à ses généraux qui
l'entouraient j'arriverai à paris
l'aigle volera de clocher en clocher
jusqu'à notre dame sans tirer un coup de
feu c'est ce qu'il va faire parce qu'il
prend de court les événements alors
qu'on l'imaginait comme un roi bien
installée à l'île d'elbe et puis vivent
quasiment comme en corse
eh bien il déjoue la surveillance de
campbell qu'il surveillait sur l'île
parce que quand belle allée voir une
jeune femme sur les bords des côtes
italiennes
eh bien il parvient à débarquer à golfe
juan a emporté l'adhésion et
l'enthousiasmé des populations qui dans
un premier temps sont assez inquiète
parce qu'ils imaginent que napoléon va
rétabli
un certain nombre de choses notamment la
conscription et le parcours va devenir
si important que le roi louis xviii doit
quitter les tuileries et que le 20 mars
pour l'anniversaire des 4 ans du roi de
rome qui est fait prisonnier avec sa
mère à vienne et bien quatre ans jour
pour jour après la naissance du ron ron
napoléon revient aux tuileries le
congrès de vienne doit déterminer une
paix durable pour l'europe n'a pas
imaginé un retour de napoléon et
retourna pas imaginer un retour d'un
pouvoir impérial teinté de
républicanisme
donc il faut traiter la france cette
fois-ci durement alors que talleyrand et
est parvenu à rétablir un petit peu la
possibilité d'une puissance française au
sein de l'europe
avec l'arrivée de napoléon les plans
sont tout à fait changer cette fois ci
les troupes décide à la fois
autrichienne prussienne et russes
décident cette fois ci de mettre un
terme à la puissance napoléonienne et la
bataille décisive et bien va se dérouler
on le sait bien à waterloo le 18 juin
1815 la cible ou jours mais on aurait pu
gagner
napoléon va engager ses troupes à à
waterloo tardivement il est à peu près
11 heures lorsque les troupes alors il
faut bien le dire aussi que les
conditions climatiques n'étaient pas
tout à fait réunies puisque le sol et
éboué que napoléon est assez malade déjà
ce qui l'emportera ensuite à sainte
hélène mais il prend les décisions trop
tardivement et s'imaginent qu'en
commençant la battait à 11h15 11h 11h15
et bien il va pouvoir repousser les
anglais avant que les prussiens ne
parvienne sur sa droite
ce sera malheureusement pas le cas et
wellington qui attendaient de manière
assez passive sur le mont saint jean la
montée des français et viendra plus qu'à
repousser ces français définitivement et
naples on est obligé de fuir et il va
abdiquer à l'elysée quelques jours plus
tard le 22 juin
à l'elysée cette seconde application qui
le connaît cette fois ci vers un dernier
exil
cet exil qui sera sainte hélène c'est
hélène c'est une toute petite île au
milieu de l'océan atlantique
il va y rester six ans puisqu'il meurt
le 5 mai 1821 à 5h49 qu'est ce qu'il a
fait pendant ces six ans a fait le
napoléon on le conduit sans jugement on
le conduit vers l'île de sainte-hélène
perdu au milieu de l'atlantique sud à
2000 km des côtes africaines à trois
milles des côtes sud américaines dans ce
petit lieu qui était sur la route des
indes et où il va être surveillé par un
joli est terrible hudson lowe qui l'a
bien connu puisque seul nom avait dirigé
des troupes corse des corses qui avait
servi les anglais les corsica granger
donc entre les deux hommes la haine est
assez tenace elles datent d'un certain
nombre d'années et entre deux les choses
vont se dérouler dramatiquement napoléon
va sculpter sa légende de deux manières
de la première c'est de dicter un
certain nombre de des hommes qui
l'entourent des textes fondateurs pour
indiquer à la fois son passé mais
également ceux qui l'imaginent pour
l'europe et pour le monde qui veut qui
va suivre
alors il va dicter alaska dans un
premier temps las cases qui qui
l'accompagné et qui est un homme avec un
parcours assez assez étrange mais las
cases va rentrer assez vite en europe où
il va publier ce texte sur le titre de
mémorial de sainte-hélène qui va voir un
grand succès à cette époque
et puis les autre mémorialiste les
autres hommes qui entourent napoléon qui
sont des sortes d'évangélistes qui
entoure le nouveau christ de cette
époque elle va devenir finalement une
légende en marche qui va alimenter un
certain nombre d'écrivains ensuite en
france comme victor hugo comme balzac
comme chateaubriand également qui par la
suite va réviser son jugement de
napoléon et ses hommes et bien vont
prendre les pas de napoléon et sa
légende c'est également c'est la
deuxième chose il va la dictée en étant
le martyre des anglais
et en étant le martyre des anglais et
bien il se fait une aura un prestige
important de martyrs ce martyr qu'il
voulait être aux yeux l'europe limeur le
5 mai 1821 commente renauld france
napoléon avait dans un premier temps
accepter le sort qu'on lui réservait et
voulait être enterré à sainte hélène
mais surtout comme il l'avait dit dans
son testament
c'était de reposer au milieu de ce
peuple français qu'il avait tenté mais
sur les bords de la seine à paris et il
faudra attendre après sa mort dix neuf
années pour que les cendres de napoléon
reviennent en france elles soient
conduites par le fils de louis-philippe
où une cérémonie formidable 15 décembre
1840 va accueillir donc les cendres de
napoléon sous le dôme des invalides
là même où elle se trouve jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
il est simplement dit que napoléon était
petit mais en réalité sa taille exacte
étaient entre 1 m 68 et 1 mètre 69
c'est à dire qu'il était dans la taille
moyenne de son époque puisque on sait
que les conscrits d'infanterie avaient
une taille moyenne d'à peu près à 1 m 68
1 mètre 69 alors ce qui le rend petit à
nos yeux c'est que est toujours entourée
de deux grands gaillards puisque les
grenadiers de la garde de mesurer entre
1,75 et 1,80 qu'en plus leurs bonnets à
poils les maréchaux était plutôt des
hommes un peu costaud donc c'est ce qui
a donné l'impression effectivement les
contemporains le décrivent comme petit
mais surtout pour dire qu'il était à la
fois de taille moyenne mais surtout très
maigre en tout cas au début de son règne
alors pourquoi napoléon mais dit il la
main dans son gilet alors on a souvent
dit que napoléon mettait la main dans
son gilet parce qu'il avait mal à
l'estomac alors c'est totalement faux
puisque cette position là était adoptée
depuis très longtemps on a beaucoup de
de tableau du 18e siècle où les gens
portraituré se placent la main dans le
gilet parce que tout simplement à
l'époque les pantalons n'avait pas de
poches profondes donc on ne savait pas
trop quoi faire de ses mains il est est
malséant de laisser pendre ses mains
donc il fallait bien les mettre quelque
part et dans les manuels de savoir-vivre
de l'époque on indique qu' il faut
mettre une main dans le dos et puis
c'est le coin c'est l'autre main dans le
gillette donc ce que faisait très
régulièrement d'apollo
là pourquoi un apollon portent-ils à
l'uniforme de colonel alors que
seulement il est général
napoléon a comme mode de communication à
l'égard de ces soldats d'essayer de se
rapprocher d'eux au maximum alors en
fait ils en étaient très éloignés dans
la réalité mais notamment pour se
rapprocher de il va porter un uniforme
de colonel colonel des grenadiers à pied
de la gare du colonel des chasseurs à
cheval de la garde bleue ouvert alors en
réalité c'était pour ne pas être
chamarré comme ses maréchaux il se
distinguait en quelque sorte en ayant
moins de décoration et peut-être
s'applique et il a lui-même le règlement
de la garde qui voulait que on avait
dans la gare d'un grade qui
correspondait au grade immédiatement
supérieur dans la ligne d'un colonel il
devenait en quelque sorte général
est ce qu'ils vivent ou acquis au milieu
de ses hommes l'image de napoléon qui
bivouaquent au milieu de ses hommes qui
mangent avec eux autour du feu et une
image un petit peu exagéré
en réalité napoléon à la paix comme à la
guerre était entouré d'un système de
souverain qui faisait qu'il était comme
a dit un auteur dans une espèce de bulle
protectrice qui faisait qu'on n'avait
pas vraiment accès à lui et c'était le
cas notamment
dans les campagnes où on montait non pas
le candidat du drap d'or à tous les
coups mais en tout cas un camp bien
organisée avec une tante qui ressemblait
à un petit palais l'ensemble étant
protégé par la garde impériale
précisément la gendarmerie d'élite de la
garde qui était un petit peu les gardes
du corps le gign de napoléon et donc non
napoléon ne dormait pas sous la tente ci
dormait dans un vide quand il dormait
dans un lit de camp dans un endroit qui
était souvent un petit palais impérial
un aplomb avait-il une santé de fer
comme dans le présent ar on prétend que
napoléon avait une santé de fer en
réalité comme tous les hommes qui
étaient ils étaient il a été soumis à la
maladie il a eu la gale il a eu des
dermatoses etc
mais il a eu tout pendant pendant sa
carrière de maladies plus inquiétante la
première c'est une forte tendance à la
18e' c'est-à-dire grandes difficultés à
uriner et qui a provoqué parfois des
réactions le rendant un peu hébété on
sait par exemple que la bataille de la
moskova là il a passé la journée d'abord
avec un rhume et puis ensuite il a passé
la journée à essayer d'uriné et ce qu'il
eût provoqué des douleurs énorme
et puis à la fin de sa vie évidemment il
a eu cette affection de l'estomac qui
qui l'a finalement emporté mais ça a été
une sphère qui a toujours été très
fragile chez lui et il en a souvent
parlé à son entourage et c'était
vraiment son inquiétude c'était de
mourir de la même maladie que son père
disait-il
alors il est mort
il a des licences en napoléon à des
descendants qui ne sont pas comment dire
dynastes c'est à dire qu'il ne pourrait
pas prétendre au trône de france mais
oui il a des descendants à travers deux
enfants naturels qu'il a eu le premier
c'est le fameux comte léon qu'il a eu
avec une lectrice de caroline bonaparte
et les noeuds et les honneurs de nu
elles se comptent les on a eu une
descendance et aujourd'hui c'est une
descendance qui ce qui existe
essentiellement par les femmes et puis
il ya eu un deuxième enfant le comte
walewski dont le fils de napoléon a même
été ministre des affaires étrangères de
napoléon iii et là il ya une descendance
à ses nombreuses garçons filles etc
on estime aujourd'hui qu'il y à une
centaine de descendants directs de
napoléon
est ce utile un prétendant au trône
impérial alors sous le second empire les
règles de succession de monarchie
impériale ont été modifiés et on a
intégré dans la liste des dix nast la
descendance de jérôme bonaparte le frère
cadet de napoléon 1er
et c'est donc aujourd'hui la descendance
de jérôme puisque les autres frères
n'ont pas eu de descendance mâle qui
représente qui forment la famille
impériale donc oui il ya aujourd'hui un
prince napoléon qui est chef de la
maison impériale
alors passons aux réalisations de
napoléon et durant le consulat quelles
ont été les principales réformes qui ont
changé respect de la france c'est une
période au cours de laquelle dans les
deux premières années on a totalement
changé la france alors non pas en
passant de rien à tout mais en adaptant
toutes les réformes qui avaient été
préparés par les régimes précédents qui
avait été pensé par les révolutionnaires
voire même certains de leurs
prédécesseurs lors réforme
administrative les départements les
préfets la restauration de l'autorité
communale réformes politiques création
du conseil d'état
création du sénat même si le sénat
d'aujourd'hui n'est qu'un un lointain
descendant et puis création d'une
société nouvelle avec au coeur de cette
de cette oeuvre le code civil
naples oms est il impliqué dans la rédac
napoléon s'est impliqué à 100% dans la
rédaction du code civil d'abord en
permettant que ce code civil existe on
avait fait plusieurs essais pendant la
révolution qui n'avait jamais abouti là
on a eu un chef d'état qui a en quelque
sorte imposé d'aller jusqu'au bout et
puis il a participé à la discussion du
code civil puisqu'il ya eu 100 séance à
peu près de discussion du code civil au
conseil d'état napoléon a participé à
plus de la moitié et il a donné son avis
sur un certain nombre d articles
c'est l'oeuvre dont il est le plus fier
la pole et on a dit à sainte-hélène que
on oublierait beaucoup de choses de lui
mais que la chose qu'ils resteraient
c'était son code
parce qu'effectivement les
caractéristiques du code civil ne sont
pas justes l'addition de loi mais c'est
une vision de la société toujours en
vigueur aujourd'hui à peu près la moitié
des articles du code civil actuel sont
les articles tels qu'ils ont été adoptés
en 1804
naples on voulait dire leur napoléon
voulait faire l'europe à la façon de son
temps faire l'europe comme nous l'avions
aujourd'hui ça à 60 ans 1
pendant les deux mille ans qui ont
précédé on a essayé de faire l'europe
d'unifier l'europe par la guerre et on
est d'ailleurs passé à plusieurs
reprises à deux doigts de le réaliser
donc napoléon louis a voulu faire
l'europe mais c'était une europe
organisé une europe tournant autour de
ce qu'il appelait un système est au
coeur de ce système il y avait lempire
français cet empire français était la
puissance prépondérante sur le continent
est-ce qu'il a libéré les peuples
européens napoléon a libéré les peuples
européens sans en avoir conscience c'est
à dire que dans les objectifs qu'il se
fixe est en politique étrangère
évidemment la libération des peuples
européens n'était pas son objectif
principal ce qu'ils voulaient c'était
assurer la prépondérance française
modifier aussi la législation européenne
pour faire disparaître on va dire la
féodalité
mais évidemment son idée n'était pas
délibéré
c'est par la suite que l'image de
napoléon a été vécu par ces peuples
comme une image peut-être pas
libératrice mais créatrice de nation et
c'est le cas évidemment en italie mais
c'est aussi le cas dans une large mesure
en allemagne
napoléon est révolutionné l'art de la
guerre napoléon n'a pas réinventé l'art
de la guerre il a simplement tenu compte
des techniques de son temps par exemple
le développement de l'artillerie qui est
alors ils étaient partir en plus donc
qui change les données de l'art de la
guerre il a beaucoup lu les traités sur
la guerre et puis il a aussi profité il
a su profiter mais c'est aussi ça être
un grand homme de l'outil militaire
exceptionnel qui avait créé la
révolution française et donc partant de
tous à napoléon
pendant très longtemps a été un
précurseur il a été très en avance sur
ses adversaires ce qui explique la
grandeur et la rapidité de ses victoires
au moins au début de son règne
la grande armée était-elle en 1805 la
meilleure du monde
en 1805 napoléon a entre les mains le
plus bel outil militaire qui ait jamais
existé c'est d'abord une armée qui est
nombreuse
c'est une armée qui est formé de
citoyens c'est pas du tout une armée de
mercenaires
et puis c'est surtout une armée qui
s'entraînent qui travaillent ensemble
depuis cinq ans puisque du début du
consulat au début de la campagne
d'austerlitz on est dans l'époque du
camp de boulogne on réforme les
régiments on réorganise on entraîne ces
hommes et ces hommes là sont
véritablement prêt à faire la guerre
ils ont de l'expérience ils ont un bon
armement ils ont un bon équipement et
puis ils ont le meilleur des chefs
donc oui le meilleur outil militaire de
tous les temps
oscar xbla
la plus grande victoire peut-être pas la
plus grande bataille puisque les
effectifs engagés étaient finalement
assez faible mais c'est une grande
victoire non pas tellement parce que
napoléon a obligé ses ennemis à faire ce
qu'il voulait et parce qu'à tout moment
de la journée napoléon a su s'adapter
aux erreurs de ses ennemis et dieu sait
qu'ils en ont commis ce jour-là ce qui
fait que c'est une bataille qui aurait
pu être une bataille extrêmement
sanglante extrêmement acharnée mais qui
en fait a été réglée plié en quelque
sorte en deux ou trois heures à la fin
de la matinée
naples ont ils vraiment
le responsable des guerres de l'époque
napoléon n'a pas à lui tout seul
modifier la géopolitique les ambitions
des autres puissances etc il est
l'héritier bien sûr de la révolution
française il est aussi l'héritier de la
politique étrangère de l'ancien régime
et il a dansé guerre une part de
responsabilité mais on ne doit jamais
oublier que en démontrant par l'absurde
l'europe n'a jamais été entièrement
contre napoléon il a fallu attendre 15
ans fin 2008 113 donc 13 ans pour que
l'europe se coalisent entièrement contre
napoléon ça veut dire que pendant les 13
premières années la présence de napoléon
sur le trône de france arrangé beaucoup
des puissances parce que napoléon les
aider à atteindre leurs buts
traditionnelle dans la diplomatie
donc oui napoléon a probablement à
partir du tournant du règne à partir de
la guerre d'espagne provoqué quelques
guerres mais il est aussi en ce sens là
un héritier héritiers da passé lointain
d'un passé plus proche et puis héritier
de ses propres conceptions de la
construction de l'europe
son seul ennemi ça toujours
le véritable ennemi héréditaire de la
france à cette époque là c'est
l'angleterre la france et l'angleterre
sont en guerre de 785 à 1815 sans
discontinuer c'est une seconde guerre de
cent ans
et on peut dire que c'est une lutte à
mort le vainqueur de cette guerre va
dominer le monde et c'est exactement ce
qui se passe en 1815
l'angleterre va dominer le monde
jusqu'aux années 1940
juin 1815 waterloo naples on l'appeler
l'incompréhensible e journée on aurait
pu à napoléon aurait pu gagner dix fois
la bataille de waterloo
simplement il faut pas oublier non plus
que c'était lui le commandant en chef de
l'armée française à ce moment là et que
l'ensemble de la manoeuvre de cette
campagne qui a duré à peu près quatre
jours n'a pas fonctionné c'est à dire
qu'après un début de campagne
extrêmement brillants les ordres ont été
mal donné les calculs ont été mal fait
et le jour même de waterloo napoléon
évidemment aurait battu wallington seul
mais ce qu'il n'avait pas en tête ce
qu'il n'avait pas compris c'est que les
anglais et les prussiens s'étaient mis
d'accord pour se retrouver toujours sur
le champ de bataille principal et c'est
ce qui est arrivé
je pense que napoléon a gagné la partie
franco anglaise de la bataille de
waterloo mais qu'il a ensuite perdu la
partie franco européenne à partir de
l'arrivée des prussiens
pourquoi d'apollon
anglais napoléon est un personnage
gentil qu'il se vit comme un personnage
antique donc une fois vaincu il se dit
que son plus grand ennemi va se montrer
généreux et va l'accueillir à partir du
moment où huit promettra de ne plus
troubler la tranquillité du continent on
va l'accueillir on va l'installer
éventuellement en gentleman farmer dans
la campagne anglaise où alors on
l'autorisera aller s'installer aux
etats-unis ce qu'il n'a pas compris
c'est que il pose un problème à la
reconstruction du continent et que
devant ce problème là les anglais ne
vont pas balancer et ils vont en faire
un prisonnier et ce prisonnier là au
lieu de s'installer dans le sexe et bien
ira vivre dans un petit cottage mais au
milieu de l'atlantique sud à sainte
hélène
napoléon avait créé sa propre
napoléon a ceci de particulier dans
toute l'histoire c'est un cas unique
c'est que c'est le vaincu qui a écrit
l'histoire et donc lorsque le vaincu
écrit l'histoire et bien oui
effectivement il donne naissance à une
légende qui l'entourent napoléon avait
très vite compris l'importance de la
communication l'importance de l'opinion
dès la campagne d'italie il a créé une
propagande autour de lui mais évidemment
c'est à sainte hélène au moment où il a
dicté sa version de l'histoire que il a
participé à la création de cette légende
développer ensuite par toute la vague
romantique
que penser du goût de voler ou alors de
gaulle pensait de napoléon à la fois des
choses bonnes et des choses mauvaises
il en a parlé à plusieurs reprises et il
a consacré dans la france et son armée
des chapitres à napoléon
il y faisait beaucoup de reproches il
lui faisait le reproche de la conquête
il faisait le reproche peut-être du
régime un peu trop autoritaire à son
goût quoique venant du général de gaulle
c'était peut-être un reproche plus
politique mais comme il l'a dit dans une
de ses dernières conversations avec
malraux on pourra dire tout ce qu'on
veut de napoléon mais ne marchant donc
pas la grandeur
est ce que napoléon d'après vous
inspirent les hommes politiques actuels
or de nos jours lorsqu'on veut faire du
mal un homme politique on lui dit il se
prend pour napoléon
alors moi je dis toujours n'est pas
napoléon qui veut il suffit pas d'être
petit pour ressembler à napoléon il
suffit pas de marcher vite mais il faut
aussi avoir ce qui a fait la force du
gouvernement napoléonien c'est à dire
une vision et une vision souvent à très
long terme
et puis une volonté je dirais une
volonté de faire c'est-à-dire de de
passer les obstacles et de ne pas jouer
la politique au jour le jour
pourquoi le culte de l'impôt nous on
reste aussi vivace avec le nombre de
livres qui sortent depuis sa mort avec
le nombre de films etc
napoléon est une énigme c'est comme
comment un homme seul ou venus de
presque rien arrivons plus grand des
pouvoirs qui ait jamais été exister dans
l'europe moderne c'est une énigme
c'est déjà intéressant en soi déjà
regardé l'histoire de ce côté là et puis
il ya aussi s'ajoute à napoléon toute la
légende napoléonienne c'est à dire tout
le 19e siècle qui est le siècle de
napoléon et au fond nous vivons encore
beaucoup sur les éléments culturels du
19e
ce qui fait que napoléon reste
extrêmement présent il est il et il est
partout et victor hugo le disait lui lui
partout
quelle est la plus grande erreur les
grandes erreurs de napoléon c'est
évidemment en politique étrangère
quand vous regardez le résultat de la
politique étrangère de napoléon il n'en
reste rien aujourd'hui un même au
contraire 1815 et une grande catastrophe
pour la position de la france dans le
monde
ceci étant la réussite intérieure elle
est colossal elle est à la fois colossal
elle est pérenne elle est encore presque
vivante dans les institutions
d'aujourd'hui et senio fait d'ailleurs
que très paradoxalement napoléon réussi
à chaque fois où il ya des pouvoirs qui
peuvent l'empêcher de deux complètement
développé son espèce d'intelligence
créative c'est le cas à l'intérieur nous
napoléon n'est absolument pas le
dictateur sanguinaire que
l'historiographie anglo saxon des cris
mais il a des gens qui collaborent avec
lui il a des gens qui parfois s'opposent
à lui
hélas il y là je dirais une obligation
de tenir compte des faits et des
circonstances
en politique étrangère ça n'est pas le
cas à partir du moment où il se sépare
de talleyrand donc 1805 1806 napoléon
n'a pas de contre-pouvoirs en politique
extérieure et là évidemment quand on
gouverne trop seul quand on décide trop
seul
eh bien on paye le prix ensuite de ses
erreurs